[Music]
if you want to think about the future of
Medicine and what that entails think
today about the largest car company in
the world
uber doesn't own a single car think of
the largest hotel chain in the world
today
Airbnb doesn't own a single hotel the
biggest medical system in the future are
going to own no hospital it's going to
be devices that are monitoring the lives
of millions of patients simultaneously
that's looking to see if you have the
beginning signs of the cancer emerging
to not treat the cancer but to prevent
the cancer from ever occurring like
that's that day is definitely time my
name is dr. Eric Schadt I'm director of
the icon Institute at the Mount Sinai
Health System in New York please call me
Eric I'm not a real doctor big data is
impact on the practice of medicine is
fundamentally going to transform the
physicians ability to personalize care
directly for you in the way we're going
to get that is you have a handheld
device that has amazing capability in
Bluetooth enable the inhalers for asthma
patients scale blood pressure monitors
EKG devices
[Music]
the sequencing of the human genome that
first genome causes three billion
dollars to sequence today you can do it
for a thousand dollars we're going to
have individualized models for each
person that maps out their health course
trajectory it will be something that
you're engaged in on a daily basis but
not necessarily actively you're just
being triggered if you need to be
because the algorithm says okay you're
at super high risk in the next year of
progressing into type 2 diabetes so if
you can catch that before the
catastrophic state then the person's not
having to come into the into the
hospital I grew up in rural Michigan had
parents that were very religious you
know to the point of you know
diminishing the role education should
play was a kind of a very curious kid
and so home I've got to the point where
I felt like to scape into the military
so it's my path
once I started college and started
taking math and computer science that it
all clicked I started in a field called
differential geometry proving things
that maybe 10 people on the planet could
get in maybe there are five that
actually cared about what you were doing
how can I put that horsepower into
something more meaningful and that's
sort of where I gravitated to bio
mathematics
I think we have to shift in culture that
says being more open and sharing is good
but medicine hasn't kept up with that I
guarantee you within my gmail is far
more personal than what's in my medical
records the data has to be more
accessible the ultimate end game is you
have this personalized therapy
specifically tune who you know you are
the stuff that's going on inside of you
if the physician can know that they can
better serve the patient better serve
the health system and it benefits
everybody
[Music]